Friday is our founders day one of our
Community Partners is Project Marilyn
here to talk more about the organization
the founder Wendy schweigart I know
we've had you on the show before but it
Bears repeating a thank you for coming
in thank you for always having me I
appreciate it and this is such an
incredible organization I've seen it
grow so much but more is needed and we
can't get the word out enough we can't
and I know I'm sure the audience is
always tired of me coming on bright and
early drinking their coffee talking
about periods but you know yet here we
are yes we need to talk more about
periods and period poverty and people
not having the supplies they need to
have a healthy dignified period Well
it's a fact of life it's a 50 of us
we'll go through this through a majority
of our life right and unlike toilet
paper most of these things aren't
readily available for a natural thing
that happens to our bodies exactly
perfect yes okay I tried to say it as
nice as I could right we want to keep it
as as palatable as possible but yes it
is it's a subject we have to talk about
and so you have these bags which I just
love project Maryland this is after your
mother it is right Marilyn was my mom we
got started cancer in 2011. and when she
passed away she shared with us that she
felt she had never made an impact which
just made me so sad because she was
amazing and so you know we dedicate our
mission of giving women dignity back to
her so now she is making an impact and
no doubt made one on your your life in
order to get you to this point right so
these are the bags that you're going to
see uh around town so not only do you
need volunteers to help put all these
things together the most important thing
is donations right donations yes so you
know we accept all monetary donations
obviously you know our dollar goes a
little bit further you know we can buy
and buy both right we can buy in bulk so
our donation you know your monetary
donation goes further with us than you
know the box of tampons you'd buy at the
store right because they are expensive
for folks at home who haven't had to buy
a box right right they're pricey they're
pricey right but we do accept all
product donations as well individually
wrapped products we have an Amazon
wishlist on our web website
projectmaryland.com and yeah we like I
said we accept everything really
important it's individually wrapped
because as you see we unpackage them and
and put them back into our own so what
goes in one of these kits that you hand
out right so this kit we have here today
is our tampon kit okay we make a tampon
kit and a pad kit because a lot of our
friends don't use tampons for various
reasons so in this kit we have 15
tampons okay 10 regulars five soup I'm
sorry ten regulars five soups okay so we
have five overnight pads Marilyn never
let us wear a tampon overnight that's
your preference uh five panty liners and
five hygiene wipes and wipes okay and so
this would essentially take care of one
cycle we hope so yes that's the Hope
right everyone Cycles different
um we just formulated these off the
fda's average Cycles five days change
your product every so often our hope is
that we're giving people healthy and
dignified period Wendy we love having
you I wish we had more time but as a
reminder they are part of our pride
Community Pride organization so we've
got donation boxes set up all over the
community as well as your organization
Amazon there's so many ways to help and
I know we I have to say it but Jay just
got a van called Maxi taxi we got our
Maxi taxi yes we love it so much pink
taxi driving around town you'll you'll
see us out there oh Wendy thank you so
much for coming in check project
Maryland out if you want more
information and please help donate we'll
be right back